hello everybody and welcome to the
biometrics nets first instructional
training video sorry I'm bothered
through my hair it's actually been three
days since I watched it but I decided
this quite spur the moments I didn't
have time to make it look very
professional it's also a min my
stepsister's room okay first of all for
the first one I'm gonna teach some
bodyweight exercises for your biceps the
reason for this is actually because I've
just come home to visit from University
realize didn't have any dumbbells and so
I thought let's get creative with the
barbell and I came up with some cool
stuff or searched online and I thought
of it myself hopefully it can be quite
helpful for you too
well they have to be honest you won't be
able to do most of it because you know
it's bad for them chances are ok so just
start with obviously you have your
ordinary hook and [ __ ] up I don't know
which ones which actually by the way
when I earlier went with the barbell
helped cement with the pull-up bar yes
so we've got the pull up in the chin up
dennah which ones which ok but there's
much cooler defecating first of all to
make your biceps work harder you can try
rocking from side to side like say this
way you're isolating each individual
bicep more making it into more
unilateral movement rather than the
bilateral movement and obviously again
it works both ways doesn't going to do
that splitting the other way around so
you did both ways it's quite a nice easy
one ok by the way the key difference
between doing it that way around and
that way around is that when you do it
this way around you're working your
biceps more and when you do it this way
around you're working your lats more
obviously both do both but that's the
key difference with ok now for some
slightly more funky stuff most this
doesn't have names because I even made
it up or found on YouTube videos so you
know you just got to learn to give it
your names I might get my own names
I should copyright them but I'll let you
know on the biometric when I come with
my own names ok so here the 1 but it
looks cool it slightly harder I think
but this one will isolate your biceps
more the smaller curl movement and at
the same time holding up your leg way
this is going to work for bottom of your
abs so that's quite cool and again I
suppose
neither grip sir you're gonna need quite
high ceiling since I suppose we could
always lower the pull-up bar
okay this is a very good one I saw Nia
get a workout video looks very neat
requires quite a lot strength but I
think it should be more than a full body
workout and I didn't done your back very
well as well so I get on this but you
know what this is cool I can say but all
I do know is that it's done cool and
it's a very good workout as you can hear
- my trembling voice
here's another unusual ones and that get
a workout video ok
I don't know again what of course but
here you're going forwards and backwards
as a poster up and down small an
isometric hold for the biceps but it
also works feels like everything else
and having your legs up like that again
is obviously good for the apps that
we've spoken about okay obviously a way
to make anything harder is to do it with
one hand that's you know most things
harder those writing would be tricky
with two hands say okay I can actually
do this whether when I think I'm good
I'll see what I can do can are myself
like that
I guess just holding yourself like that
would be a really good workout may not
be a good isometric Coast but what you
can do how many remember I'm noting this
one nakid if you can't do one pull-up
like yours truly yesterday trying like
this this is actually tough on the
blissing so they've been climbing in
that too long but yeah you can do that
obviously on both side and I present
quite a good alternative work as well
and another way to trails just one and I
talked about this in my article how to
do one pull-up I did easier to do as my
job choking in the background
disconcerting
ELA okay hey wait another way you can
train to be able to do that and it's
actually it's basically doing negative
so instead of pulling yourself up you're
jumping and then letting yourself down
as slowly as possible and to do that for
a couple of rest it really starts to
burn
but the vendor on the other side as well
feelin okay but anyways you don't just
have to do that negative idea for
one-arm pull-ups you can do it if you
can't do a pull-up at all with both arms
or turn ative lee if you just say it in
this workout to failure on the flat bar
do as many as you can imagine that those
means I can I can do loads the madam you
don't read you can and then once you got
to the end you start just forcing
yourself on a couple of last ones when
you've got nothing left to get doing
negative like this it will really flush
all the rest of the energy out of your
biceps like I say often on the by matrix
cheating is bad but cheating is better
than not doing it at all so once you
can't do any more to squeeze out more
that way it's better than just giving up
and you'll really feel obliged to do
that on every set another way pull-ups
or chin AppScan various by how quickly
you do them and if you read my time
division articles I always talk about
time division that's my patient adept
method nicely patented but I like boots
it anyways um but say even talking about
yeah so what you do is you can do you
can alter the speed as how quickly you
do them so you do as many as you can
quickly and then you start doing them
really really slowly for example you
might do ten really quick ones I don't
know if I've done ten on up because I've
encountered but we'll just say that's
ten then we go really slowly like say
with a full range of movement so cool
the first ones white to put up and then
if you follow that immediately by full
pull-ups you'll feel that there's
already a lot of strain on the muscles
and you're working both fast which down
the slow twitch muscle fibers that size
and your work and you're doing CV as
well as resistance so you're kind of
building the size of the muscles as well
as cutting the fat and it's just a
really good way of working out anything
so yeah I highly recommend that okay and
at the extreme end of the spectrum okay
so you're not doing a bit really fast
you're now going as slow as you possibly
can is to just do hang I'm you saw me do
that earlier with one hand but basically
just hang like this and you can do it
for about if you can do it for three
minutes I mean that's really
what I like to do is put on a song
preferably rocky and just hang until the
end of the song and then that way well
you kind of know that the end of the
song has come in so you can dig deep and
get that last little bit of effort but
yeah that really hurt as well that's
really good for the lats and them to do
it the other way around again you've
been working the biceps more that
isometric hold
let me do that and in front of
immediately with the aforementioned
white cut I mean you're just really
mixing out and you should be starting to
see this you know if you did all these
listened exercises that one that one you
know fast slow legs up legs down you can
have an amazing biceps workout we've no
need for dumbbells or anything so they
have it an absolutely massive workout
that you can do for your biceps using
just a pull-up bar and they're not
expensive it costs five quid from Argos
you can carry it anywhere with you
pretty much mother fish strange walking
around the pull-up bar I meant more like
in a bag or something yeah so there's no
excuses not not to get great massive
biceps and if you use all of these using
the principles of time division which I
talked about more website and in my book
book you say yeah that's my book my book
you can buy it off the website by the
way if you zap it to of time the vision
that would be to start off really slowly
with this tool fully extended spine pull
up and then work your way to the quicker
and quicker one and we nasan each set
you know really mix it up hit the fast
twitch muscle fibers and the slow twitch
you can see be in there and some
resistance then you're going to end up
with an amazing workout and I promise
you your biceps will burn the next day
and there's so much variation there I
mean just keep it going and keep your
muscles guessing keep trying new stuff I
mean you can just make up something like
I've just made up you've got your arms
like facing different weight just made
that up
cool you know so you know just keep
guessing and then bending stuff and send
it to me if you find nothing useful
you know keep the useful for gently
users that's what Bruce Lee said so
anyways thanks for watching hope you
found it useful
good luck training your biceps visit the
bio matrix net and buy yourself a copy
of my book
you
you